we begin today with the numbers they are
climbing have you heard new daily
coronavirus cases could more than double
from current numbers that's according to
the nation's top infectious disease
expert the u.s. added almost 45,000
cases yesterday alone
another near record increase around 1200
more deaths were reported taking the
u.s. total to more than one hundred and
twenty-seven thousand as you heard dr.
Anthony foul she testified yesterday we
could hit a hundred thousand cases a day
without major changes Janet shamlian
joins us from hard-hit Houston Janet how
does this affect plans for the 4th of
July which we're all looking forward to
Anthony good morning Texas has put
limits only on outdoor gatherings of
more than 100 people but with the
holiday weekend ahead medical officials
and experts are very concerned and
that's because since the last holiday
weekend
Memorial Day hospitalizations here in
Houston have jumped more than 300% any
health care system in the world will be
pushed to the brink dr. Faisal Massoud
is the critical care director at Houston
Methodist Hospital he's asking Texans to
wear masks to help bring down the curve
to where it was in May please you gotta
stop this thing now Houston area ICUs
are at 93% capacity statewide
hospitalizations are up 332 percent
since Memorial Day more than 6,500
Texans are now hospitalized with
coronavirus an all-time high and demand
for tests is outstripping supply at
several sites Texas is one of at least
18 states that have either paused our
world back tree openings due to the
corona virus so has California where new
cases rose close to 70,000 in the last
two weeks a 42% increase governor Gavin
Newsom warned of a new round of
restrictions the framework for us is
this if you're not going to stay home
and you're not going to wear masks in
public we have to enforce clearly we are
not in total control right now at a
Senate hearing to
today dr. Anthony foul she warned
lawmakers that surge in cases in several
states have put the entire country at
risk but I think it's important to tell
you and the American public that I'm
very concerned because it could get very
bad 37 states reported increases in
their 70 average for new coronavirus
cases Tuesday
Arizona's average was 83 percent
compared to two weeks ago and his cases
there continued to climb frontline
workers like Erik Jones are increasingly
exposed pretty much all we ran for
months were Kovac calls
back-to-back-to-back Jones is a
firefighter in Chandler he says before
he caught the virus he doubted its
severity I lost consciousness and ended
up on the ground like it it was that
intense thinking it was just like flu or
something like that but it's not man
it's real with cases rising across the
country New York New Jersey and
Connecticut are now asking travelers
from 16 states to quarantine for two
weeks if they come to the area and
Massachusetts is going even further
asking anyone who travels from outside
the Northeast to the state to do that
famed quarantine Tony a lot of concerns
up here at Jana thank you very much